That part of only one sessional
for all sessions of mathematics.
See, I have talk.
I don't know.
I am saying only for next
session because it is going to
be very important.
OK.
We are aggressive.
Yes, Sir.
You're agree.
Yeah, I think.
So.
We are needing.
Yes, Sir.
No issues in.
The Saturday last message?
OK, so Sunday.
The.
No.
We can extend it.
Saturday is OK.
Yes, Sir.
Saturday is OK.
And now you, you you decide if
it is Saturday you give me.
Some days late.
I am OK even with 8:00 PM to
10:00 PM class 10:30, but that
should not disturb your routine.
The Sunday is better, Sir.
No, no, please, please.
Yes, it's Saturday is good.
Saturday will be difficult
because I am staying outside
India.
I will not be able to continue
because it will be late for me
He can.
to.
It's 10:00 PM in the night.
He kept Baba.
So my point is, Sunday at what
time you have DSD and what time
you have cost?
The same thing.
It's a MD said.
Is there cost is not
dissatisfied?
Because it's not there with
today.
But he said.
Not given any scheduled time as
of now.
So can I take the Sunday 4 noon
session from 10:30 onwards?
Mostly 10:40 will be our cost
session 1040 to one.
So can you take it?
So better if.
This this boat will be morning,
I think.
Can can he take it at can you
take?
Can you take it at 3:00?
O'clock you can have a lunch.
Yes, yes.
Yeah, yeah, that works.
Three o'clock, yes.
Yes. Yeah.
Yes, Sir.
That works.
OK, so.
3.
To 6 minutes, Sir.
I will take it the Sunday three
3:00 o'clock to 5:30.
Is that OK?
Uh-huh.
OK. OK.
Yes, said that looks.
Getting.
Yeah.
So if.
Yeah, that should be fine.
You don't.
Mind, we don't have any classes
before lunch on Saturday, so we
can take the class your class,
we can shift your class before
lunch and then you can extend it
to the lunch and then we will
have this time left for like we
can have two hours left for our
next class.
So we can do lunch in that time.
Now I am OK I am.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
It will be difficult.
Please, let's let's don't
squeeze the things, please.
Yeah, yeah, it it will be
difficult.
It will be difficult.
I'm requesting everyone.
No, no, please.
Have clusters.
You need to have it 3.
You have to.
You have to understand
everybody's comfort.
They are not squeezing, we are
just change.
Serve because both the days will
be tough for us.
Yeah.
See continuously.
Nobody will be able to
concentrate.
No, no, no.
We need some.
Saturday is fine.
Saturday, we can accommodate how
much ever we want, but Sunday
would be difficult.
Saturday, for me it will be
difficult to engage her because
you know I'm I I have the time
limitation.
Only two hours of time I have to
take lunch also.
OK, think there is no
continuous.
But you can watch according
also, right said.
Maybe we can offline do a
polling something.
Set up like we.
Properly.
We have just two classes on
Saturday.
I think we can.
That I think we should discuss
it later, not during the
They probably can go for voting
set.
sessions.
Yeah, we can take a poll.
Yeah, voting will be better,
yeah.
Yeah, later. Yeah.
OK, so so so, OK.
Yeah, we can decide it later,
Sir.
So let me.
OK.
So let me give you let, let me
give you two options, Sir.
One option is that you tell me
by the end of this class you run
a poll.
Right now in some other WhatsApp
or something like that and you
tell me alternatively you tell
me by the end of today, one of
you just mail me saying that we
can have the classroom this time
to this time on Sunday, but you
can't expect me to finish
problems.
Also finish the slides also and
make it understandable to you
within those two hours.
The two hours has a certain
pace, but if you want me to go
out a little slower pace, you
have to give me more time.
So Sunday, if I don't have the
right side bound.
If you want me to work out one
more problem, I can workout one
more problem.
If you want me to do something
else, I can do something else
also, but it should not be so
tight that you know somebody
says here it is already 1:00
o'clock and we are hungry.
So you will break for lunch,
then the entire momentum goes.
We can do even even 22 breaks
for 10 minutes for coffee, tea,
Yes, yes, makes sense.
hygiene, break, etcetera.
That is all accommodate able OK.
That Sunday, 3:00 PM is fine.
Yeah, makes sense.
Anyway, it is regarding so.
Whatever.
Makes sense.
So, so one of you.
A big.
So one of you write an email to
me with just one of you.
You did nominate yourself and
write an email to me.
Then.
I'll schedule the class and put
it in the calendar.
The gizzard.
Is it possible to have one pool
now you can initiate that pool.
We can directly see that.
Yes, Sir.
Right now it's off.
In teams, only they can do it,
Sir.
We can get the answer now.
We can directly, you know,
instead of waiting, we can just
one click, we will be completing
that.
Yeah.
There is a small problem there.
The problem is an.
The problem is not everybody's
present in the class now.
But even by EOD, how can we be
sure?
Sure, that everyone will respond
such.
You have you have written a mail
or you have written this to all
your classmates.
It has gone by Google forms or
something like it.
If they're not, respond to that,
then.
So tomorrow somebody should not
blame Nam.
I was.
I was in my in my office and I
did not have access to this
stuff.
So people decide on Sunday.
Work anyways, so like if someone
doesn't join, they can always go
back and see the recording.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's what that recording
is there.
Agree.
OK, so my point is my point is
that you people decide and you
So anyone if you can check.
let me know I am OK with
anything.
3 Saurabh, you can create a poll
and we'll post it in our
discussion group in the break
time.
Maybe everyone can vote and we
can know the result by the end
of the day so that Sara also
will manage Will will update us
the timings here.
Yeah.
RER select suggest one thing
when kisser VENKITESWARAN
You can.
Let's nominate 1/4.
select.
Suggest one thing during the
break hygiene break.
We can have this pool that time
all the people will be present,
right?
OK, OK.
Huh.
Then then it will be better you
know, instead of just, you know,
uh, delegating.
And you know, keeping in the
last or something like that, we
can have one time there here and
then we can close this out,
You send the one mail to me.
right?
You send one of, you send one
mail to me.
That's it.
I'll finish it.
OK.
OK. Take care.
So you are able to see my
screen.
Yes.
OK, now the concept of linear
independence dependence.
It known?
Or should I revise it a little
bit and then finish it off?
So please revise.
Umm.
OK, so should I do it in my
notebook?
Otherwise it.
I have SPECIFIC question.
What?
Uh, the note.
Yeah, yeah.
Yes.
Yes, please in the notebook.
Notebook.
OK, fine.
I hope you are taking notes of
whatever I'm writing.
Nah, I am in your posting it,
but it is better that you also
take some little notes so that
when you write one say it'll
things will be clear.
So this is MD S Session 3.
OK.
But we agree that we will not
disturb others.
If you don't have anything to
ask me, you put your system on
mute.
If you have something to ask me,
just unmute yourself and then
you can throw the question.
So now there are three concepts
here.
One is linear independence and
dependence, second is generating
set.
30s.
Span.
4.
Basis and 50s dimension.
OK, so now I will come come to
the first point.
Yeah.
So what is dinner?
Independence dependence.
You have a vector space V and
then you have a set of vectors
Like.
V1 up to VN.
Now we call them as linearly
independent if any combination
linear combination alpha 1V1
plus A2, V 2 plus all the way up
2A NVN.
If it is equated to 0, this will
imply that A1 equal to A2 equal
to equal to alpha N equal to 0
as the only solution.
Now this only has to be
highlighted.
Agree wherever you want an
example, you should ask me like.
Otherwise, I think that this is
all known to you.
OK.
OK, in case if not, then we went
up to VNR linearly dependent
agree.
Yes.
OK, fine. What?
Agree.
Please.
Agreed, Sir.
Agree.
What are they?
OK, fine.
Now the second one is there is
something called generating
sector.
Second, now you have.
Let's say U1U2 up to UM are such
that.
Any Member V belong to V can be
written as.
Some A1 you want plus A2, U2
plus all the day up to Alpha MUM
equal to B then.
You want up to.
UM is called the generating
center.
Agreed.
He is.
So any we can be written from
from this from this set, but you
be linearly combine them then it
is called the generating set.
OK.
Agree.
OK.
Third, you find a.
That but the for the what the
span if I say we want up to be N
But the.
then the linear span of V1 is
basically nothing but all
combinations.
You put A1, V one plus A2, V 2
plus all the way up to alpha in
VN where alpha belong to F this
is called the linear span.
So you can you combine them with
whatever possible combinations
you have and this will all get
into something called as a
linear span. OK.
And what is app here belongs to
FF?
What is?
If it's a field, the scalars.
Great.
That is set up scalers.
What?
Setup is scalers.
And.
This is a field of scalars.
Yeah, and.
Be one is a vector, A1 is a
scalar.
And are we saying when we say
set we mean a vector space here
or just as it?
No, no, no.
It becomes a bit of space is a
different thing, but you put all
these things into this.
The.
OK.
Yeah, in this case, we're just
talking about a vector set.
We are not worried about whether
it is a vector space or not.
This is set of all vectors of
this form.
So Sir, basically we are
combining the vectors to
generate another vector which is
also a part of the original
vector set.
Hmm.
Yes, in a vague sense.
So let me give you so should
should I give you some little
This we went to.
understandable stuff.
Yes.
Should I give you some little
understandable stuff?
It's it's the the previous one.
Uh.
Yes. Yes, Sir.
Yes, Sir.
It's at least.
Yes, Sir.
OK, so typical example I take is
I have a a tea.
Uh, this is APARNA.
What do you call tea leaves?
Then I have sugar.
Then I have water.
I have milk I have.
I hope masala.
And this is my V1.
This is my V2.
This is my V3.
This is my V4.
This is my V5, agree.
OK. Umm.
Yes, Sir.
Now what all I can generate is I
will take some spoons.
A1 spoons of spoons of tea
leaves.
Add it to A2 spoons of sugar.
And A3 ounces of water plus A4
ounces of milk plus A5 spoons of
masala. Agree.
Yeah.
Yes, Sir.
How I keep changing A1A2A3A4A5
then what will it generate?
I will generate all sorts of
things.
What will it generate?
You tell me.
Only you will generate that of
different quantity if you change
What?
I can generate.
the.
So you can generate a tease of
different varieties, kind of
Different types of thing.
Be different.
Variety of different quantity,
different quantity, different
masala tea, yeah.
It's been quantity, different
quality.
No, you, you, you, you tell me.
So for example, I can I can do.
quantity.
And I will.
I'm writing a few members of the
set and there is something
called black tea.
I will just combine tea leaves
and water and I will take black
tea.
Maybe without sugar.
I can take uh black tea with
sugar, correct?
Yeah.
You know that?
Then I can take masala tea,
PASCOAL Arti without sugar.
To go outside.
I can do a plain milk.
Umm.
I can make dilute milk.
I can make milk with sugar.
You see what all I can generate
so I need to just play around
with the A1A2A3A4A3 agree.
Quickly.
Agree.
Now that is what you do with
vectors.
Yes.
Also you have vectors.
You can maybe take one set of
A1A2 up to alpha and you can
take a different set of A1A2 up
to alpha north.
Now whatever it generates, so
every time you keep collecting
these vectors, you try to
generate this and then you see
you put all of them in a dubba
that Dubai is called the linear
span of here V1 up to be here.
Agreed.
OK. Agree.
OK, so you will generate so many
varieties because you can have
less sugar variante.
You can have more sugar variant
if you have more sugar.
Your A2 is more.
Umm.
Yes.
And so here I work.
If, if, if.
One more thing I want to
understand here.
But yeah.
One more thing I want to
understand Sir.
Here is the field field means
any variety.
We can either milk or tea or
only water.
Something like that.
You everything.
Only water is only you put
A1A2A4A5 equal to zero.
That is also one possibility.
OK.
So then what is the difference
between the generating set and
If I.
this?
Because even in the generating
set we have vectors and the
combination linear combinations
vector will generate one more
vector.
Uh.
Correct.
So what is that going?
So so so I am saying this is
what this is going to be.
Yes, Sir.
What is?
No, if I if I can continue the
same example if I want to
prepare coffee now, we may be
able to prepare coffee from this
ingredients.
No, no.
And.
No, no.
In the generating set, I said
any we belonging to V can be
written as this combination
agree.
Yes.
That is what a generating set
is.
Now in this case I can.
It.
This is with the reference for
the post code.
If I have it, if I have a
generating set there, if I have
a generating sector, then any
element in that vector space can
be written as a linear
combination, agreed.
Yeah, I agree.
But if I have only two
ingredients, it cannot produce
every element in my vector
space. Agreed.
Yeah.
So I am talking about if I want
coffee or I want paneer butter
masala.
I cannot make from these things
correct.
Can I make paneer butter masala
from V1V2V3V4V5 impossible,
It's.
right?
Don't know.
Correct.
But what I can generate out of
this is something else that is
called the linear span.
Now, if every element in this
can be generated from these
things, then it will be called
as a generating set.
So if you go to a restaurant in
the restaurant, they have
finitely many things, right?
And.
In the restaurant, if you.
But since then you can, Sir, can
we consider like the like?
Say we have tea leaf example.
You're given 5 to V5.
Let's say if you add coffee also
as V6, then does it that those
Yeah.
If you put it there, so I I'm
going to come to that in the
set of vectors are called
generating set.
next point.
If you are given only two items,
so then what?
So for example, example if I
have a set where I have just a
milk and uh sugar, what kind of
generate?
What is the linear span of this?
Milk.
Milk with sugar and milk without
sugar.
Was that with the?
So what milk without sugar and
milk with sugar correct?
K.
Plain milk plain sugar.
Some sweet also.
The I am gently talking about
liquid.
If you just want to have one, I
mean I I want to have
combinations here.
No, if you just want to have
sugar, you can have sugar.
Also taken now the point is
there is something called
generating set.
The generating set is something
like.
You walk into a restaurant,
let's say you walk into a 5 star
restaurant and then the Visa
restaurant has lots and lots of
ingredients, right?
So let's say it has 500
ingredients.
Agree this is the first
ingredient.
This is a 500 ingredient.
What does it generate?
And number of 80s.
So you can generate everything
what is available in the
All. All.
All.
You're very delicious.
All what is all what is there in
the menu bar correct?
industry.
Yeah.
Yes.
You get my point.
OK, but yeah.
Yes, Sir.
All what is there in the menu
card so when somebody says I
Yeah.
need paneer butter masala, what
he does is he takes something
from here.
He can take something from here.
He can take something from here
and he can take this.
He can combine these two in some
proportions.
OK.
And then he can prepare paneer
butter masala, correct?
Correct.
Yes.
OK, but you can't ask this
fellow to prepare your dining
table.
Correct.
And they will not be the
generating sector.
So whatever ingredients are
there in in the kitchen, he'll
be able to generate the dishes
which are there only in the menu
card, outside the menu card.
He will not commit anything,
correct.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yep.
Yes.
That is what I'm saying, but the
linear span is different and the
Sounds.
That so the minute.
I.
and the general is a generating
set.
Is something like you give me
any item?
I will be able to generate with
a set of items.
Live near Spanish.
You play around with the set of
items, it may not generate
everything it generate.
So the.
Something's only agree.
So the agree this linear span of
the generating set will be the
vector space is what we are
saying the.
But maybe can we assume this
way?
Sir, let's say vector space is a
whole and and then generate.
This setting is it is for the
whole vector space and then
these small span is only a small
subset of that vector space.
Hello.
Well.
Yeah.
Can you hear us, Sir?
I think I lost you guys for a
minute or so, so that is the
difference between generating
set and the linear path.
Yeah.
So it is saying with.
But we can we say that the
linear span of the generating
set is the vector space itself.
Can we say that?
Yes.
OK.
Yeah, you can say that.
I'm going to come to that now.
So one more question before we
move on linear independence.
Yeah.
Just one question, very small
question this there in like I
Yeah.
just want to confirm this, the
system, the linear equation
system represented by two
equations X + y + Z equal to One
X + y + Z equal to four right?
Is this system linearly
independent or dependent?
One X + y + Z E equal to four
uh.
Or is this linearly independent
system or dependent system?
There is nothing like you near
independence and dependence of
systems.
Linear independence is only for
vectors.
OK.
So, OK, one one small question
there.
So generally like what I've been
reading this if system if a set
of vectors is linearly
independent then a system this
Yeah.
is corresponding system will be
consistent right?
So that is.
Penny.
Is that true to a linearly sorry
linearly dependent system of
vectors is consistent with
something I read everywhere?
Basically, but you know, like
this example, it's not so right.
These two vectors are linearly
dependent, but the system itself
is not consistent.
No.
What is the system you are
talking about?
Systems in India.
Independence.
You're mixing A22 minute terms.
Terms that what I'm saying is,
suppose you have alpha 1 * 1
vector, I will call it as X1 X
2X1X is 1 vector plus A2 times
other vector.
I'll call X3X4 plus A3 times and
X.
Suppose this is equal to X7X A.
OK.
No.
Now this will have a solution
only when only when X1X2 taxi
Yeah.
export X by X6 and X7X8.
Are linearly dependent.
OK.
So.
You will be able to write one of
them as a linear combination of
the others. Agree.
Agreed.
Now that is what is required.
OK.
So, OK, fine.
In just the in case they are
linearly independent, they do
Let me reprint.
not have any solution.
OK, I just got it.
So just let me rephrase the
question for a a system AX equal
to B if the vectors in the in a
right the column vectors in a,
Hmm.
they are linearly dependent.
It is possible that for some
values of B, the system will
still be inconsistent, although
the vectors are independent.
Basically right.
The yeah, I want to hear now
event to Anor linearly
And not really.
dependent.
Suppose then.
No, no, I.
No, no, I I I am not saying A1
to a in a linearly independent
A1 to A1 line.
The independent and it does end
by end square matrix.
Then it allow units solution.
Right I they're literally
dependent.
You give me one after a NR
linearly independent then.
Suppose there Live.
X equal to B, where A is a N
cross and matrix.
We'll have and you need to
solution.
What?
Agree.
Agreed.
OK. Yeah.
OK.
If they're linearly dependent,
we can't comment on any X equal
to B.
We we can't conclude anything.
It depends, right?
In not.
You're gonna need it. Suppose.
Yes, you will have infinitely
many solutions.
Ohh no solution. Also right?
That's the example I gave X + 5
plus equal to One X + y + Z
equal to 4.
The vectors themselves are
dependent, but there is no
solution.
No, the point is here it is
inconsistent, right?
It is inconsistent.
I have talked about consistent
systems only.
Only consisted.
I have talking about 30.
OK, fine, but this.
If you're talking about this
1114, then if you do, R2 goes to
R 2 -, R one, you will get A1111
and A0003.
That.
Now rank of gay will be equal to
three, but rank of yeah.
But B will be equal to four.
Therefore, this is inconsistent.
How inclusive systems will have
no solutions.
That's right.
But the call the column vectors
of a in this case are dependent
actually, right?
Yeah, dependent.
But but the OK that was my
question.
Yeah, this possibility is.
Huh.
Now the point is I, you know, we
already I I thought we were.
We were using the theorem which
we did in the last class.
Your system of linear equations
can either have a unique
solution, no solution, or
infinitely many solutions
agreed.
Yeah, yeah, I got it said, I
think I think the mobile.
Now, uh, so I am not talking
about inconsistency at all.
If it is inconsistent, there is
no solution.
I mean, then we throw it away
directly in case it resolution
and you find something like
having linear dependence, then
you'll have infinitely many
solutions. Agree.
OK.
Got it. Yeah.
OK, fine.
Sure.
Now the 4th point, if you have
the generating set.
That that is.
Linearly independent.
Then it is called the basis.
OK alternate thing is B1 up to
BN.
He's a basis of we.
If.
We went up to VN are linearly
independent and.
Linear span of V1 up to VN equal
to be.
Agree.
Now I just want to give you some
examples.
If you see for example 1001 and
two three now you tell me.
I consider these three elements.
Now you tell me.
Any point in R2 you tell me any
point?
2142.
What?
The in the 3131.
P1 Now I write this as 3 * 1
zero.
That's one times zero 1 + 0 * 2
three.
I've been able to write it.
It's a linear combination.
Yeah.
OK, so if you give me any point
AB, I will write as 8 * 1 zero
Yes.
plus B times zero 1 + 0 * 2
three correct?
Yes.
So the entire the R2 can be
generated from these three
things, but now will it become a
basis?
No, because why there's two or
three itself can be written as 2
* 1 zero plus three times 01,
correct.
Yes.
Great.
About.
So this generating set is your
over killing the generating
sector.
But what can actually generate
is 10 comma 01.
This is good enough for it to
generate the entire arc to
correct.
Agree.
You help me with me?
Here.
He uses.
OK, so this is the Funda.
So from generating set
generating set can have more
elements you cut down so that
all the elements are linearly
independent here.
Then you'll get a basis.
Alternatively, you start with
any nonzero element.
A plus.
I want to find a basis for R2.
I start with any nonzero
element.
Let's say I start with two
three.
I will check whether I can
generate all the elements in in
R2 using 2-3.
Can you generate every element
using 2-3 alone?
No.
You give an example which you
cannot generate.
You know.
No.
Five you cannot generate.
You what?
Both.
Both both 4/4.
Fighting and what, 57?
474447.
1 foot 1/4 cannot be generated
on 2/3.
Yes.
OK, so you please add 1/4 to
this.
Now check whether you can
generate every element in R2.
From these two you will be able
to correct.
Yeah, yeah.
That means this becomes linearly
independent.
These two are linearly
independent and these two span
the entire R2.
So this becomes a basis.
This is Frank.
This is also a basis for R2.
Now you can see that the number
of bases can be infinite, but
the dimension which is basically
the number of elements will be
fixed.
So dimension of this is 2
because number of elements is 2.
Dimension of this is also
agreed.
Now I can also write another
basis.
Uh 37422.
This is also basics.
But number of elements will be
just to agree.
Yeah.
How this is also business like
this, this.
No.
You tell me any element, I'll
generate it.
7000.
Uh, I like 10/10/12.
OK, you want to generate 1012?
I will say this is nothing but
alpha times 37 plus beta times
Umm.
14 to two, OK.
422.
Correct.
But 3A plus 4 beta equal to 10
and 7A plus 22 beta equal to 12
Correct.
7 revolve Plus 2218 required to
12 yes.
Pro plus 22.
correct?
Yeah.
So can you not write this as
three 4722A beta equal to 1012?
Intel.
And 10:12 yeah.
Uh, yeah.
Yeah.
He's invertible 66 -, 28 liter
minute which is non zero.
Then yeah. OK.
Therefore, alpha beta equal to
if I call this matrix as yeah,
Hmm.
That's.
it is nothing but a inverse into
1012, correct?
OK.
In version 210 to.
So I'll get the alpha and beta.
Yeah.
In this in this.
Yeah. Two questions.
Two. Yeah.
OK, OK, in.
So you give me any element, I
will be able to generate it with
these two vectors.
So what I have told you is you
you can do two things.
That.
One is you start with a very big
set and start, uh, cutting down
members so that it becomes
demailly independent from the
generating set.
At the same time, generating and
then you'll end up with the
basis or you start with the
nonzero element.
You start adding elements to the
set till the linear span of
that.
Here's the entire vector space
and you'll be able to do it.
Agree.
Does this also mean that any two
linearly independent vectors
It's.
Nothing.
will be able to generate R2,
right? Any.
Yeah, correct.
Exactly.
Yeah, because the dimension is
too.
Not R2's dimension is 2.
You will be able to do that any
two linearly independent vectors
will be able to span this.
OK.
Then I I'm sorry.
Yeah.
I I if I'm asking where in you
know bad question.
R2 is what R2 I'm.
I'm just trying to.
The set of all set of all two
dimensional points that is R2.
OK, OK.
Are you?
I don't say that you only 91.
So that means A2 dimensional
array sort of thing, right?
Two dimensional matrix. Umm.
Hmm.
Correct.
So.
Is it clear?
So, Sir, when you say inverse
10-12, how can we regenerate
this using this inverse 1012 I
mean.
You can find a inverse
multiplayer 1012.
You'll get alpha and beta.
Very wrong.
Hmm.
Hmm, yeah, that, that that value
of a, if you're going to make it
Ugly.
Well.
OK.
inverse and multiply with 10
till probably we can get.
Yeah.
Correct.
Then you will get alpha beta.
Umm.
OK.
So a inverse nothing but
transposing the things, right
Venkat Sir.
Why transpose inverse not?
Why transpose only for
orthogonal matrix?
Inverse OK.
Transpose and inverse are same,
otherwise you have to inverse
it.
OK.
Yeah, it's equal to B.
Now you multiply both sides by a
inverse the inverse B.
This is nothing but I X equal to
a inverse.
BIX is nothing but X, which is
equal to a inverse.
Agree chicken.
Yeah, yeah.
So I have told you something.
Linear independence.
Dependence.
Then I've told you generating
said the linear span basis and
dimension agree.
Have you forgotten something?
Don't think so.
But anyway let me check.
Then kisser this nodes where you
are keeping.
Yeah.
I'm I'm very much sorry.
I tried to find it out.
I'm not getting this notes this
type of note.
That is the easy see finding
notes is the easiest part of my
course.
I'm seeing in models.
You go to this place, you go to
this place in teams.
In. Yeah.
Yeah.
Is there?
I'm.
I'm I'm seeing this only.
OK, you find you.
You go to find Sir.
Umm.
I'm fine.
So you have this not.
Class materials, but I'm not
able to see him just saying.
Why it should be visible to
everybody, Bubba.
It's a PDF.
It is the MFDS PDF file PDF
files.
I think he's asking about notes.
Yeah, it's a video file.
OK, OK.
OK, I thought something
different this I OK.
Right.
Yeah, it's there.
OK.
Yeah.
OK, fine.
Thank you.
That, yeah.
OK, fine.
But this is what I had to cover
in uh session Lecture 2.
Umm, so we have given some.
So for example, this is not a
basis scanning.
Somebody tell me why why this is
not a basis?
The 2nd and 3rd order needed.
Is it linearly dependent?
So they are linearly and you can
check it using any of the things
they'll be linearly independent,
but still it is not a basis.
You need 4 for our four.
Dimension should be 4 Bracco.
Well, yeah.
Because there are three three
vectors, we need 4.
Well, it's matters.
Yeah, it's a four dimensional
space R4, no three can be
linearly, linearly independent.
Spandex.
You require 4 vectors.
OK.
Yeah.
You should.
Agreed.
So one more vector we need or
what?
One more vector which is
linearly independent with this
is required.
OK.
So it's OK. OK.
OK, uh, now this is the these
are just results which will be
useful to you in some theorem
proving so.
We consider only finite
dimension vector space or
dimension of the vector space.
We consider with only be finite
in this case, but there is
something called topological
space.
Uh.
Which had infinite dimensional
vector spaces and I'm not going
to consider any of them here
because all our mission learning
things are finite in number and
we're going to use only finite
dimensional spaces.
Now if U is a subspace of B then
dimension of U will be less than
or equal dimension of V and
dimension of U equal dimension
of V if one only if uh U equal
to B OK.
Yes.
OK, so these are just two simple
consequences which are there
now.
I have already given these uh,
things.
Now, how do you find these
basis?
The basis is basically you try
the.
And you try finding out the RREF
form and then you can find the
pivot columns.
They form a the basis.
So for example, if I take X1 X
2X3X4 and this is a subspace of
R5 Now everything is fine
dimensional.
Are you able to see that one 2
-, 1 -, 1, one?
There are five elements here.
Now we want to check whether X1
X 2X3X4 constitute the basis for
the subspace U.
OK, So what are the two things
it should do?
Quarterly basis, there are two
conditions it should be able to
Should be.
It should be linearly dependent
linearly independent.
And then maybe.
span lead in independently.
And.
We.
And.
So you you write them as columns
and do the RREF and if you try
to do the.
Are you of this you will try to
find whether you are getting
them to be linearly independent
or not.
Yeah, linearly independent.
Then you you it will constitute
a basis, agree.
The guitar.
Is it possible to sew please?
This one.
Yeah.
Because.
Can I use octave?
Difficult.
OK. Yeah.
Yes.
OK, Sir.
OK, Sir, use the OK.
OK.
Can I do a smaller example?
Yeah, yeah.
Smaller will be helpful when
this definitely.
Because this will it will take
take 10 minutes for me.
Yeah, it's very.
Yeah, I can understand. Yeah.
I'll take 10 minutes for me to
even do this now.
Yeah, yeah.
So so I will, I will give you
this example can 123 and two 1
-, 3.
Uh.
So you is spanned.
22.
By, let's call it U-1 and U2U
spanned by U-1 and U2.
Now is this a?
BITS isn't agreed.
Yes.
When you realize this is, this
is OK.
Basis for our three error.
What?
Basis for R3 is what we're
looking for, right, R3?
No, no, it is a no, no.
You is a subspace of artery.
And R3 is nothing but the this
one ohh 3 universal space OK.
Look like.
3 dimensional space.
This is ugly items.
Yeah.
OK, OK. Umm.
The room where you are sitting,
this is 3 times space and you
Umm.
are spanned by you on a new two.
Now is you on and you two are
basis.
Hmm.
Then it is very easy to check
now what you should check
whether they are linearly
independent, correct.
And so they're linearly
independent here.
So how do you check any
independence?
You just put them in 12321 minus
3, correct?
Umm.
And then you will do the roll
action business.
So what did you get?
How many pivot columns did you
get?
They do that here.
1.
Yeah, 222.
If I do, if I do, R2 goes to R 2
-, 2, R one.
Who? Who?
What will I get?
Two or two 120 and minus 3.
And that's three.
Then do R3 goes to R 3 -, 3, R
one.
Three 0 -, 3, -, 6.
0 -, 9.
My.
Ohh minus nine.
Yeah, OK. Yeah.
Now, what are the different
columns?
Ohh one.
1.
One and minus 3.
What are the pivot columns?
1.
But the.
1.
Pivot columns 1.
One and two.
Running to.
Both are one.
Both are favorite columns, both
are.
One and two when.
One is this, yeah, yeah.
These two are feeling 2 pivot
columns.
This is.
How how this is to when they
said one, I can understand 100
is there.
What do no consulate row wise?
If you see from the first row,
you have first nonzero entry,
here the second one nonzero
entry is here, so these two are
Yeah, yeah, correct.
Yeah.
proven columns, no?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, correct.
Yes. Yeah.
If you have a situation, so I'll
try drawing a different thing.
If you have a situation where
you have a 100200 uh 3 -, 2,
four, suppose you have a system
like this.
Hmm.
The first nonzero entry here is
1, correct?
Yes, yes, yes.
The second nonzero entry is
here, and the third nonzero
This, yes.
entries here.
Yes.
Have you done some mistake?
No stupid column here.
No.
Because to be.
Have I done some mistake?
This like the same column cannot
have like.
No.
No, it's OK.
Have been going down.
I know.
No, no.
No, for for, for, for it's.
Please understand if the third
one is not the.
No, this is not a favorite
table.
You can do elementary
operations.
It's the whole should be 00.
This phone line, no third has
to.
Support can be made.
Non.
Be zero.
Yeah, that has to be.
You know, it should be 0.
0 right.
It has to do, yes.
Feel that means you have the
first nonzero entry here.
Umm.
And the second nonzero entry in
the 2nd row.
2nd row yes.
So this becomes one pivot column
and this becomes one pivot
column.
Why this is the other 1200 is
not a pivot column is because
200 is nothing but two times
100.
You can generate a second column
from the first column, right?
Yeah, multiplying by two, yeah.
But you blame me too, so that is
the reason two is 200 is not a
pivot column.
If the number of pivot columns
are there, it means that they
are linearly independent.
Agree.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. OK.
OK, that means it is a basis.
Why you change 4 to 0?
And what is the problem with
that earlier when you?
Why?
Why is?
What is the problem?
When you return 3 -, 2, four,
Sir.
Earlier you said this is a
mistake in this.
Hmm.
Yeah.
The the 3 -, 2, four, because it
has to be 0, right?
Because that number was OK.
The the last four one has to
become zero if we are creating
the generating the things.
So consecutively then the next
number was non 0 so it should be
Yeah.
non zero it is.
Dude actually goes through
active.
There was not an area for my
think Hari form, yeah.
Let's do R2.
Why do you get it?
If these two are three plus 2R0,
it will become 0000.
0.
It will become zero.
It will come, yeah.
It should be.
No, check whether it is in RE
form.
Umm.
Correct. Yep.
One yes, it is there and this is
theirs.
OK.
Like this?
Got it.
But.
OK.
So the same baby proof.
So the same day the above one we
can make 9 into 0 right in the
last row.
The two years on this, but minus
nine is that becomes 0.
What is it?
Which one?
Yeah, but still it will have
only two, huh?
Minus the fail.
Yeah, two.
Yes, exactly, yes.
I'm ready too because, because
because I thought you will do
Yeah, that will be true.
Yes, yes.
that part.
So what is the condition to
check whether it does, uh,
I don't sleep.
linearly independent?
You try to find out the number
of pivot columns and the number
of vectors.
You would column is 2.
So for example, if I give you a
system where it is 100200 and 3
He worked.
-, 1 and 0, are these three
vectors linearly independent?
Yes.
No.
No.
No, no, no, no, no.
Only there are two pivot pivot
columns, no.
2nd dependent on 1st.
OK, which can?
One yes, yes, yes.
But there are three vectors.
OK.
But the second column is.
Can be generated from first
column right?
By multiplying by two so that is
not really linearly independent.
Exactly.
So if I if I.
So if I if I call this vector
V1, if I call this vector V2, if
I call this vector V3, I will
have a situation where two times
Is equal to.
V 1 -, 1 times V 2 + 0 times V3
equal to 0.
Equal to.
This zero is a vector.
Yeah. Yes.
Are all the coefficients zeros
here?
No.
That means they're linearly
dependent, right?
Yes, Sir.
That's what you find out using
this REF.
What is the equation 2V1 minus
V2?
How you are you are you busy?
Your voice is not very clear.
Can you be a little louder?
So have you worried?
Arrived at this equation, my 2 V
1 -, 1 V 2.
Yeah, the The thing is because
the second column can be written
as two teams of first column
because it's a non pivot column,
right?
Ah, yes, OK.
But I write that 2 V 1 -, 1 V 2
+ 0, V 3 equal to 0.
Agree.
OK, fine.
Yes.
So when you when we, when we
when I use it in cooking for
example I check where linear
dependence or independence based
on whether I can get one item as
a linear combination of the
other items.
So I will write a few items.
You stop me whenever I'm
crossing the linear
independence.
So I take a salt.
Is it linearly independent?
No.
Linear eat.
Do.
Yes.
Yep.
Yes, yes.
Yes.
Yes, yes.
OK.
Then sugar.
Yes, yes.
Yes.
Uh people that.
He powder people, yes, yes.
No.
Yes, yes.
It's I'm saying.
Umm just yeah, yeah.
Hey, the game is very simple.
Check if any one of them can be
got as a linear combination of
the other elements.
Can you get solved from sugar
and tea?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, no.
Sugar from salt and tea he from
salt and sugar.
So.
Never.
No.
No.
Milk powder.
No milk powder, sugar it is
sugar.
No.
Is there right and milk powder?
I'm.
That means.
I'm just trying to understand,
yeah.
Yeah, yeah, correct.
Milk is also.
OK, so I.
So that means it is not.
It is not, uh, linear
independent.
Yeah.
OK.
So let let.
So let let me let me write only
milker.
Yeah.
Then the moment I say this is
and the.
Uh harmonic?
And no, it it doesn't.
Then I will say Chili's.
You know.
Metric.
Yeah.
No.
So these are all linear
independent.
You know.
But.
These are all linear
independent, yes.
These are independent, but the
moment I put some masala powder.
Then it will become linear
dependent, right?
Exactly.
Anything can be, yeah.
Yeah, gotta why this is linear
dependent because you can write
masala powder as a linear
combination of salt, turmeric,
chillies et cetera.
Anything it can be.
Yeah, it can be mixture of
anyone other thing.
So that is what I am trying to
do.
The moment I add 200 I'm getting
this to be 2 times 100 so it
You.
becomes independent.
You know.
I never to get the second column
from the first column agree.
Umm.
Yeah.
That is how you make you are you
understand whether this is
linearly independent or
dependent.
Umm.
OK.
Sept said.
No. Yeah.
I had a quick question here.
Within basis, Sir basis basis.
What?
I had a quick question here Sir.
So for establishing linear
independence, if we get it to
RAJKARAN form, is it enough or
should should we get it to
reduced row?
You can do with both.
Baba. Doesn't matter.
OK, Sir.
Sir Roy Echelon will.
OK, reduced draw will always be
unique, right?
Yeah.
So if you if you.
Yeah, the news story is unique.
You can you you can do RREF, REF
whatever business you want.
OK.
But then you try to find the
pivot rows and the non pivot
pivot columns and the non pivot
columns.
Got it.
So yeah, that part is clear.
Just wanted to know if.
If you have non pivot columns
then you can do it.
RREF is a few more steps after
REF.
So you're spending more energy?
Yes, yes, yes, yes, got it.
You can do it with less energy
itself if it is computationally
Got it.
Yes, Sir.
Thank you, Sir.
intensive.
OK, fine.
Now there is something called as
a land 90 theorem.
While many of my colleagues said
they were not very happy with
this, putting it here, I thought
for whatever it is worth, it is.
It is given here because it will
help you in solving some
problems.
Now what this says is you try to
find the rank of a matrix A and
the dimension of the null space.
Now you know null space, the set
of all vectors which solve a X
equal to zero.
You put them all in a Dumber.
It'll be a vector space and and
you can find the dimension of
it.
If you add these two, you should
get the number of columns of a
which is N agree.
Motivating, not getting.
Sir, can you please repeat the
statement?
So yeah, what is it now?
Yeah, yeah.
Can you do an example and throw
you?
Yeah.
Yeah, you're going to say that
will better.
Yeah, that's better.
You said.
Yes, please, Sir.
OK.
I will ask one of my left
tenants to help me with
something upper N pritika can
you give me a good matrix A?
Or maybe I will take it.
So let me take 1224.
Umm.
Agree.
Now, what is the rank of a?
1.
Then copy.
What?
2.
One we this is 1 because if you
do the RREF business, you'll get
And.
2.
How?
How how one?
a 1200 number of nonzeros is 1.
00 OK 1/2.
OK, now you try to solve AXE
equal to zero, which means 1224
times X1X2 equal to 00.
Hmm.
So this will give you X1 plus
2X2 equal to zero and two X 1 +
4 X 2 equal to 0, correct.
Umm.
You should.
Now the second candy question is
not special.
It is exactly the first
equation, but multiplied by two,
correct.
Yeah.
But.
Yes.
Got it.
So you have basically yeah X1
plus 2X2 equal to zero, which
To be happy, infinitely many
solutions.
means whenever you take X2 equal
to K you take X1 equal to minus
2K.
It'll solve correct.
Yes.
Umm.
So what is your X1 X 2X1X2 is of
the form.
Minus 2K K.
Oh, this is nothing but K *, -,
2, one correct.
Yes, yes.
And.
Now something which is like done
like this.
This is generated by so solution
space solution is generated by.
Minus 21, correct.
OK.
Yes.
Yes.
Now, what is the dimension of
this?
Dimension IS11.
Dimension of nullspace.
Equal to what if you add rank?
Plus dimension of null space.
This will give you 1 + 1 which
is equal 2.
Really.
This two is nothing but number
of columns of a.
No, Jesus.
Please.
OK.
Agree.
Umm.
Angry.
Yes it.
Said how do we dimension of null
space one?
Because it is generated by only
one vector, no?
Let's see.
Umm.
And.
For this example, dimension is
one, yeah.
OK.
Yeah, for this example dimension
is 1 and argued example only.
So I would I would the rank of A
is 1 so 1200.
That would make, yeah.
1200 You do R2 goes to R 2 -, 2
R one, then A will be reduced to
1200, correct?
Yeah, right. Yeah.
I defined rank as number of
nonzero rows in a row reduced
form, correct?
It is one row only 10.
OK.
OK, fine.
So it is 112 is a one day row,
000 right tick.
Thank you.
Umm hmm.
Yeah, that thing.
OK, so this is what is a
consequence.
Now there is one more thing I
wrote for the general case when
N being odd.
If N is odd, let's say N is 7,
then can you have dimension of
the null space of A and the rank
of it to be equal?
Lucy.
No.
No, because rank of A+ dimension
of a both are equal means it
No.
will be an even number right
rank plus dimension.
Yeah.
Yes, yes.
The.
But N is odd, so the sum of two
numbers which are equal it
cannot be an odd number.
Correct, but these are some
little consequences.
Yes.
The which can be drawn.
So what is the maximum value of
dimension of null space of a?
I'm more of call, honey.
Hope.
Yeah, these are both integer
values, right dimension, rank of
and dimension of null space of
a, right?
N minus rank.
What?
N minus rank.
Maximum.
No, no, I am asking what is the
maximum value of dimension of
NFA.
Yeah.
And.
You can.
Presumably and minus one and
minus one.
I'm not sure.
In minus one.
And minus one.
Uh, so rank of yes.
Yes, dimension of rank of YA and
dimension of end of YA is.
Yeah.
And there is end here.
Now you can have a a system
where for example, if I take a N
to be let's say five, you can
have this to be 5.
This to be 0.
This addition is 5 correct 415
and so on.
Yes.
What will be the last entry?
14145.
But.
145 why not 055?
0 means null metrics.
Why not zero will be.
A zero is a null matrix, so only
you can go up to if it is a non
0 means all the rules are zero.
The twins and right.
null matrix you can have rank of
eight to be 1.
Yes.
The dimensional space would be
equal to four, so it basically N
N -, 1.
minus.
And minus one.
There's a consequence of this
speaker, but are we set to start
with the second, the third
Lecture?
OK.
Yeah.
So VENKITESWARAN tell we have
voting now if you can set
He said.
voting, please.
I want to spend 10 minutes.
OK, please.
Uh, now how do I?
We can quickly do.
How do I do it?
Yeah, that's also I have.
I was also facing the same how
we can do it?
We can do in teams channel is
there.
We do further either way.
To actually somebody, then one
second, Sir.
Here somebody has posted in the
chat with different signs for
routing set.
So I think that will help here.
See here.
But uh, react on this message.
No change to schedule.
Yeah, we have done that.
Shall I copy and push the same?
Yeah, somebody has done that.
But, but The thing is that
everyone has not voted.
See, so this one.
Everyone has not voted.
That's the reason.
And that's when you take your
time and do it now.
Yeah.
Yeah, let's do.
Actually I have done most of the
people have done already.
We can do one once again.
Hmm.
Once again, yes, one second.
Can you can you suggest some?
Can you suggest some order one
algorithm?
Yes, Sir.
Who is strongly opposing to
Sunday 3:00 PM class till 5:30
PM?
It's a good question, Sir.
I am not opposing.
I am.
I'm with you.
No, no, no, no, no, don't.
Don't talk if you're not
opposing, keep quiet.
You're the voice of you.
I'm fine.
You cannot.
You cannot raise your hand.
You cannot give some symbols, et
cetera.
I simply want you to unmute
yourself and then say I object
or you just keep quiet.
That I object.
OK, one.
I I object too.
I object.
2/3.
I object.
All right, 678910.
The object.
Are you get?
I object.
You know that.
I object.
11/12.
I object.
131415.
Sir, I object.
I object.
161718.
Object.
Idiotic.
19.
I have the.
I object.
21.
Checked.
I object.
22.
23 Yeah, you should object only
one step.
Yeah.
OK, I'm getting 23 out of 168.
So can we conclude something
now?
OK, I will post the other
question.
What about Saturday?
From 8:00 PM till 10:30 PM, how
many of you object?
I object.
We objected.
I have the I have the.
I am good, I I.
I object.
234 object.
Maybe.
I have the I have checked.
Fight.
The object.
6.
789101112.
ID object.
Think you have it.
10.
I object 13.
I object I object.
Well I object.
141516.
I object.
Right. OK.
I objectives.
17.
I object.
1819.
No, I object, Sir.
Say your Jack object.
I.
20.
I am.
21.
We need to wait like.
I object 222324.
I object.
Bye.
I object.
25.
I object.
26 OK this order, one algorithm
says people are OK more people
Page.
Object.
are OK for Sunday at 3:00 PM.
In.
So can we conclude that?
Please please please.
Yes, Sir.
It's a.
Yes, Sir, I'm getting visa, yes.
Yes, speaker.
Please please.
Yes, Sir, Friday is.
I will.
OK.
Schedule the schedule it.
And give it.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you, Sir.
OK.
Thank you very.
Others, if you have.
Thank you, Sir.
Much.
Some other freedom and you want
to talk to me?
You organize the session.
I will be willing to do it
through the week.
Don't worry about that.
If some of you feel that I
should do some.
One.
So is that.
So so there will be no class on
Saturday.
Said excuse me, Sir.
Yeah.
Yeah, no class on Saturday,
Sunday.
There will be class only on
Sunday.
OK.
This is why every week, Sir.
This is and you only that I
plug.
This is one day.
This is one day for 16th.
OK.
That's OK.
And I might use a similar thing
for the nonlinear optimization
where I need to do little more
like things so that will be 11th
or 12th session.
I may do one more Sunday.
No problem, Sir.
OK, right.
So.
I'm going to catch up on certain
norms.
An army.
Some concept of a length in
higher dimensions, we used to
say in one dimension it is very
easy.
You just measure the distance
from the origin and you call it
a norm.
Now, how do we do it in multi
dimensions?
It actually there are some few
properties of norms.
The absolute homogeneous
properties that norm of Lambda
axis you take a Lambda out with
a model assign.
Now you will find always
triangle inequality which is we
have.
Why this triangle inequality is
because you always say that the
sum of two sides of a triangle
is always greater than the third
set when X&Y are vectors,
you know norm X plus norm Y is
measuring the diagonal and this
will be more than the length of
X plus white.
OK.
The third one is the positive
definite, which means to say
that whenever you have an
elector, except now Max is
always more than equal to 0
because it is denoting some
length and nomics is equal to 0
will imply that X is equal to 0.
This right hand said zero is a
vector.
Please understand when I write
excess of bold X and write as a
normal zero don't get confused
scale of zero.
It's a vector 0.
Now, there are some typically
used norms.
One is called the man had a norm
or the one norm.
You'll take the sum of absolute
values of all the elements of
that.
And racked up.
This is called the one.
Now you can also do the two
knob.
Here you take the square of each
element, add them, and then take
the square root.
So these are two simple norms,
and you can really prove the
second one is slightly
difficult, but you can still
prove it.
It is just involving little
algebra, but all the three
properties can be proved agreed.
Agreeable.
Umm yes.
OK, now there is something
called, uh, the dot product dot
Yes, Sir.
product is basically nothing,
but you take the corresponding
elements in X&Y, you
multiply them and add he.
Basically it is extraposed way
which is called the dot product.
Now there is something called as
a bilinear mapping.
What is a bilinear mapping is
because he's something where
there is a linearity with
respect to the first argument
and the second argument.
Now, if you take uh ohmega with
two arguments, you take the
first argument as Lambda X + y
and the second argument of Z.
You can split it as Lambda times
X comma, Z Omega of X comma Z
plus side times Omega of Y comma
ZUC is linear if you take it to
the second argument Omega of X
comma, Lambda Y plus side Z you
can again take the laptop out
and you can.
You can do this site.
You see the both the expressions
are one and the same.
Are you able to see that?
In the sense it is able to take
out the the thing and you can
Easter.
have only the the, the the
function inside.
You can take the constants out
OK.
Hmm.
But uh Venkat, just quick 11
doubt here.
Yes.
Yeah.
** is same but there is
Z&Z&Y.
Yeah.
No, no, I'm not talking about
exit.
I'm talking about the nature.
Umm OK.
I'm not talking about the exact
value.
Ah, OK, good.
I'm saying you can take whatever
you did in line number one, you
Hmm.
take the the constants out there
and you take the function.
Yeah.
The same thing happens in two
right.
Yes, yes, yes.
The first thing it is exed and
YZ, the second one it is XY and
XZ, but then the the the the
overall process is the same.
We.
The values are different.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
So you mean to say the functions
are nothing but Omega of XZ or
YZ, right?
Yeah, correct.
But the constants are out, so
that's the thing.
No conscience that out there,
and it is linear.
That is, yeah, yeah, yes.
OK, suppose you have B as a
retail space and this Omega as
the bilinear mapping.
Then this Omega is called
symmetric if if you interchange
the X&Y you should not have
a change in the value, so this
is Omega of X comma Y equal to
Omega of Y comma of X.
It is called positive definite
if Omega of X comma X he is more
than zero and Omega of 0 comma
zero is equal to 0.
Agree this happens for every
Omega fix comma X is more than
zero whenever X is not equal to
0 and Omega of 0 comma zero is 0
when inside the Omega there are
two zeros.
The.
Those are vector zeros and the
equal to is a zero.
That's the scalar 0.
I hope you are able to
understand that.
OK.
Yeah.
So you can define it now.
So could you please repeat it,
Sir?
Sorry but.
Yeah, sure.
What I'm saying is this Omega is
called symmetric if if you.
If you flip this X&Y, you
don't change the value.
OK, store.
And this is called positive
definite if if you have a
nonzero X this Omega of X comma
X is more than zero and Omega of
0 comma zero is equal to 0.
Which means in the sense that if
my ex off value may be of a four
or uh more than actually one or
two or three, which is more
which is actually greater than
zero.
If it is zero, it is zero.
No ** not ** is a vector, X is
not a scalar, X is a scalar.
That is a positive or no is OK.
This Omega function, if you take
X with X itself, the answer
should be more than zero as long
as X is not equal to 0X is
different from zero.
OK.
When you take X equal to 0, this
will become pretend to 0 right
now.
OK, OK, Sir.
Thank you.
Yep.
And then line send.
The second one.
So could you please go back to?
So there's a Lambda X and how
the Lambda is that I mean and
Yeah.
the Lambda we are taking out,
but is it does not have the
Lambda at all, right?
Like how it is coming.
Sir, I am not getting it.
They're very, very Lambda is not
there.
The Omega within the bracket
Lambda of X + I of Y comma Z
Yeah.
right and it is equals, yeah.
So the definition, yeah, you.
Whenever you want to do that,
you take X with respect to
Z&Y with respect to Z and
put the plus in between these
Hmm.
two, and then whatever Lambda is
there, you take out here
whatever Sai is there you take
out here.
OK.
Yeah.
OK.
It's like, OK, fine, that's a
separate vector, is that it
OK.
serves a separate vector. OK.
Yeah. Correct.
Now.
If you have a positive definite
symmetric bilinear mapping, then
it is called as an inner product
that you would have studied in
in the in the college and
etcetera.
Now the only point is they
define inner product and and dot
product in the similar way.
Dot product is an example of an
inner product in the product is
much more, much more advanced
compared to the dark.
A simple dot product.
OK.
We, along with this dot product
and the the the inner product is
calling the product space.
We will show that I know I
symmetric positive definite
things will play a very
important role now.
There is a there is a.
There is a very small theorem
which says that for a real
valued finite dimension vector
space B and then ordered basis.
But I will tell you what an
ordered basis is now.
We'll say that a function from V
Cross V to R is an inner product
if and only if there exists a
symmetric positive definite
matrix a such that X&Y the
inner product is nothing but
some in some.
Uh botnet system?
It is X hat transpose AY hat
now, which means that you are
going to define XY with the
inner product in terms of X hat
and Y hat.
Now, what are these X hat and Y
hat is how you represent X with
respect to a basis.
Now that is all contained in
this.
In this matrix A and also in the
exact and Y hat.
OK fine now.
I will not get into the details
of that, but I will just try to
get you some basic idea that
whenever there is something
called Yifan only if in the
theorem it goes two ways.
One is from if you assume
something on the left, you have
to prove something on the right.
If you assume something on the
right, you have to prove
something on the left.
OK, but before that, what is an
ordered basis?
You find the basis for a vector
space and then you give it a
number B1B2B3 and don't change
it any further.
That is called an ordered basis.
So you take a basis of V and you
order it in some way.
Stop.
So for example.
Can I take my notebook and write
the ordered basis?
Yes, yes, yes.
Because this order disks.
So you take for example 10 and
01, you call it as B1 and you
call it as B2 and don't change
anywhere during an analysis for
the same set of theorems or
whatever it is, you start using
it.
This becomes an audit basis.
Agree.
Whatever you're doing with
respect to 10 and 01, you can
also do with two, three and four
seven.
So in this case you keep this as
B1 this as B2 and don't change
the number for the rest of your
analysis.
Then this.
This becomes an ordered basis,
OK.
Agree.
OK.
So why I will tell you there is
a little later because we are
going to obtain something which
is dependent upon how we write
these matrix elements.
So there are two things.
And you're the say that and the
the function B from V cross B to
R do you understand this V cross
V2R?
Should I explain this?
Please explain VENKITESWARAN.
Today explain this or you know.
Yeah.
Please, please please.
Venkat Sir, please.
OK, fine.
Yes, please.
Yes, yes.
OK, so when there is a product
of two things, uh.
1224.
Suppose I call a function F from
uh M cross.
Yes to tea.
What it means is the function
takes 2 arguments, the 1st 21 is
some small M this belongs to
capital M and comma there is an.
And umm.
Yes, Sir.
This yes, is a smallest which
belongs to capitalist.
Now this cross is basically to
indicate that every element will
be of this form and this will
give you some tea.
Would that make?
Bear, this tea belongs to the
capital city, OK?
Can we have an example, Sir?
Agree.
Yeah, but for example, yeah, I
will call the simple interest
function.
Can you call the simple interest
function?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
My name, OK.
Please, please.
Don't.
Simple interest function.
This is basically a function
from a.
Some real number.
Cross some positive real number
and N is some positive integer.
Uh.
Into some positive.
Neil #2 if positive real number,
you know why?
Thank you.
What you do is you take simple
interest function.
You take a principle.
Hmm.
You say that that you're
interested for these number of
years and then you say it is
with our percentage of interest.
Umm.
Mobile.
Yeah.
This will give you P into N into
R by 100.
This is a member of R correct R
positive.
Umm.
Yes, Sir.
Yeah.
He has three arguments and I
have told you for which sets
these arguments are coming.
Umm.
It's wake up.
OK.
Umm.
OK.
So in this case, what I'm saying
is, is something like the
Right.
function is an inner product if
and only if there exists
Me.
symmetric positive definite
matrix a such that X&Y inner
I am in.
product is nothing but X hat
transpose AY hat transpose Y
hat.
Now, hey, there is somebody who
has not muted your system.
Ohh doesn't moniece
Chakravarthy.
Sorry, sorry.
No issues.
No problem.
So one way is to prove that if
this is an inner product, then a
is symmetric positive definite,
such that XY equal to XA
transpose AY hat there is the
other way where A is symmetric
positive definite such that the
operations are defined by this.
Then the operation defines an
inner product.
Now these two are two directions
and I think we have given the
proof in this in this sensor.
Do you want me to go through the
proof or you think it is?
It is enough if you know that
then enough part is
characterized by matrix A and
with respect to some ordered
basis.
Sir.
So can't explain it again.
Here escape is denoting the unit
vector of X&Y.
There is nothing like unit
vector.
What is the escape exactly here?
I'm then I I will do the proof.
Then you understand what escape
is.
OK, exactly.
Yeah.
So we prove the direction so XY
be the inner point between the
vectors X&B, so you know
what is an inner product, right?
What is an inner product?
We can utilize all the you.
Component wise product in
addition.
How do you?
Yeah, we can utilize all the
properties of India point which
I defined previously.
Just umm yeah, yeah.
So if you remember this.
Yes, yes, yes.
OK, OK.
We can.
We can use all these things.
So what I'm trying to do is let
XY be an inner product between
the vectors X1, YB.
Now X is a vector and we have an
ordered pair VI in V.
So will I not be able to write
XI as a linear combination of
all the bias?
Yes, we can write.
You can write them because this
is an ordered basis.
Don't change anything in their
basis, because if we change the
basis in the the order didn't
everything will go for a task.
Similarly you can write Y as
Lambda BIDIT for some I for some
Lambda I agree.
Umm and.
Now, since it is the inner
product, you will be able to add
X&Y as.
This some place comma this sum.
Right now you can take both the
sums out and then because why
Umm.
you can take the sums out.
Can you tell me?
Because of the linearity, right?
Yes.
OK, so now.
Since both are linear, since
both are linear, that's why you
are taking the sums out and then
I and Jay are varying from 112.
Yeah, that's why I'm digging.
Yeah.
I send Jason.
I'm.
I'm taking it out and you'll
have Sai BIBJ in a product
Umm.
Lambda chain now this BIBJ inner
product is basically the vector
that the matrix called A and the
Sai and Lambda J will give you
this exact and Y hat transpose
agree.
BABJ's coming is becoming A and
Lambda J is becoming Y hat and
PSI is becoming X hat transpose.
Yeah.
When?
When you, when you, when you
change from this scalar notation
to the vector notation it you
get ahead.
Umm OK.
Is the provision of the X vector
basically right?
Ohio.
Not coefficient of X vector,
Bubba.
This is written in the in the
expanded mode.
If you want to write it in the
compressed mode, you put all
these elements into this X hat
transpose.
OK.
Yes, but.
So does the AIJ is nothing but
the inner part of BA&BJ now
excited why you had a dentist
which represent the coordinates
of the original get test with
respect to the basis vectors.
If you have X&X&Y hat,
then you'll be able to express
Umm.
exact as a linear combination of
this, uh, X&Y.
Right.
So that is what is contained in
this exact uh and by head.
Umm.
Speaker, now the inner party say
explicitly mentioned in terms of
the matrix.
Yeah, symmetries because BIBJ is
same same as BJB in the product.
So A is also a symmetric matrix.
So.
Now for all X.
Yeah, which are different from
zero.
You can also say that X
transpose X is going to be more
than 0 because the inner product
of the the inner product is
positive definite means this is
also positive definite and so it
is X bar transpose.
This actually X hat.
Sir, I think this is this is the
same thing.
APARNA, can you make can you
make a note of this afternoon?
This is the same thing we proved
in LECTURES 0, right?
We did not prove this in Lecture
0.
Yes, Sir.
I'll I'll make a note of it,
Sir.
Yes, Sir.
Uh.
It's butthead AX.
Yes, Sir.
Now the other side is very
similar to this.
We are going to use make use of
the the the symmetry and other
properties to get this thing
done.
It is likely voluminous.
Yeah, I suggest that you start
doing this and in case you have,
you have any issues you can get
back to us.
I will also try to expand this
and put it across as a.
As a node in the in the canvas
discussion, this is not very
tough and then you can I think
you can easily follow this.
Now there are, say, a few
questions based on this and I
think it is it is better that we
get into those questions.
And can you symmetric positive
definite matrix have less than
full rank? Uh.
This is what is the is the
question.
So can I pose this question
here?
Which question?
Canon.
Which where where.
Hey I'm writing it down now.
Yes, Sir.
OK please.
Tell the symmetric positive
definite.
Matrix.
Now.
Less than full time.
Is that question?
So yeah, he's symmetric.
Yeah.
This positive definite.
Can you help?
And K less than him, Aman.
Cross it.
Let me see.
Here's a question.
What is your answer?
Can can.
So.
No.
OK.
Uh.
Uh, so SAIRAJ, Vijay.
Development of a same as a of J
comma I this you agree because
Yeah, yeah, this is.
it's symmetric, correct and you
have extrasport AX is more than
zero for all X every time not
equal to zero.
OK, now say whether a can have
rank less than N.
Sir, what is XFL this X?
What is?
His ex.
Hey, you've been a little
louder, Bubba.
So what is this X?
Is this X transpose and X?
For any X party, any exit.
We have frank listening.
So yeah, it it cannot have
anything less than full run.
Wait.
It is possible.
Because the space for equal to 0
only, we can have the in a.
The you know the transfer the X
is greater than zero for X not
equal to 0.
So only when X equal to zero we
can have.
But what has it got to do with
the rank of a?
OK, they mention it.
Umm.
I can give you one hint.
What does the rank validity
theorem state?
There's drank coffee plus
dimension.
They mention A+ dimension of
null spaces, right?
But of column.
That is the end.
Number of in.
Yeah.
OK, that is sufficient to answer
this question.
Agree.
He has full rank, so he has full
rank in the sense it's N right.
Thermostat.
We said.
Drink kisser.
Now X transpose.
Now X transpose X is more than
zero for all nonzero X, right?
Yes.
He is.
So what are the elements are
allowed in the null space?
Only 0 vector.
So for example, what is null
space of a?
Only hello.
All space.
Of the east, the solution space
governed by the solutions of
eggs and what is he?
OK.
Agree.
Yes.
Now for example, let why he
belong to null space off.
A little.
Game therefore AY equal to 0,
right?
Yes.
And why is not equal to 0 is
null space of behavior.
So that means AY equal to 0.
Therefore, why transpose AY will
be equal to 0 correct whenever Y
is not equal to 0?
You see.
I suppose if he lays it called
20 and why is not the white
transfer site?
Yeah.
For some, why not equal to zero?
Yeah.
Or for somebody for some way,
which means this is not positive
definite, right?
Hello.
Here is not positive definite
correct.
Agree.
Yes, Sir.
Which implies only.
Why equal to 0 is allowed?
In the now space.
Which implies dimension of N of
A will be equal to 0, correct?
Yes.
Now that I mention of rank of YA
Plus I mention of that space of
a will be equal to gain.
Now this is 0.
So what is dimension of RA?
And.
In.
He has good, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, that's what full rank was
in.
That's what. Yeah.
But this is how you prove it,
and for this only I had put this
stuff Dave in the previous
slide.
Agree.
So Venkat said just one doubt.
You know, I just please clarify
me is not positive definite,
right?
What does this mean when kisser?
No, I am saying, OK, uh, I don't
know that.
Umm, I'm sorry, I actually I'm
trying to I yeah.
No, no one second.
Have you seen LECTURES 0?
Yes, yes, RAMKISHAN I've seen.
Yeah.
So if I take a matrix A which is
1002, let's say easier positive
Umm.
definite.
Yes.
It is because if I take any X1X2
and multiply with 1002 and
Umm. Umm.
multiply with the X1X2.
What I'm going to get?
710021.
X1.
Yeah.
So this is nothing but X not
square plus 2X2 square correct?
Yes, yes.
Now X1 square is always more
than 0X2.
Square is always more than zero
and this will be more than 0
Yeah.
Yeah, that's why it's a good
thing. Umm.
whenever X1X2 is not equal to
00.
Correct, but this is positive
definite now when you have
Yes, yes.
OK.
positive definite and you want
to find out the solution of the
null space.
So if I have null space of a
while trying to find out what is
Umm.
there in Null Space Office
suppose null space of A has a
vector Y.
OK.
Out of all the elements, if I
have some element called, why it
can have several other elements
also?
Super like say null space of A
has a Y, so by definition this
is a nonzero vector, correct?
Umm yes.
Which implies GAY equal to 0.
Umm.
Because in terms not space
correct I can multiply with
Yes, yes.
white transpose on both sides.
Yes.
But this will say why transpose
AY is equal to 0 for a Y which
is nonzero, which implies a is
not positive definite.
Because by the definition of
positive definite, whenever you
have a which is nonzero, why
transpose Y should be more than
0.
But here you are getting Y
transpose away to be equal to 0
which is a condition right?
Yes.
So I cannot have any nonzero
element in null space or null
space are in contain only 0.
Hmm.
So I've been null space of a is
containing A0.
What is the dimension of
nullspace of a?
Deal.
Umm.
Now apply the languid theorem
dimension of RA plus dimension
of nice piece of year will be
equal to N Now this is zero,
Zero.
which means dimension of out of
yeah will be equal to N.
OK.
Yeah. Yes.
And then yeah, all right, yes.
So yeah, has full drive.
Got it.
Yes, yes.
Yeah.
APARNA Kritika, are you able to
digest this?
Yes, Sir.
His.
I don't know who is saying yes.
Good thing, good thing out.
That I'm.
You are able to relate with the
angle theorem.
This concept external spose X
more than zero.
Yes, Sir, I got it.
It's you and I got it.
Ohh OK fine.
That is the reason I have that
that is the reason I had put it
there.
OK, now there are lots and lots
of properties with respect to
this symmetric positive definite
things and symmetric positive
definite is the one which is
going to guide us through the
machine learning algorithm.
So I will be always talking
about this positive definite
matrices.
Now there is something called a
canonical basis.
Maybe I will write it here.
The easiest to basis you can
write for RN.
This is the end dimensional
space.
Will be something like.
You start with 1000 everywhere.
Then you start with 01000.
This is called the canonical
basis.
It will have N elements.
This is the last element, so
this is typically called as an
E1E2 and this is called the El
where EI is basically the IT
position has an ID and all other
positions are high.
Position has a one was, he said
he has a one and all other
positions are filled with zeros.
Now this is a basis.
You know that this is linearly
independent because if you put
them in a in a in a factor in a
in a matrix form, you will get
an identity matrix which is
already in RREF form.
So it is linearly independent.
It will span every element.
Every element can be written as
a linear combination of elements
in this basis element.
Now this is EA.
Now if I matrix AN cross N is
positive definite, then I told
you that any nonzero excel, uh
like that will satisfy.
It'll satisfy X transpose X is
more than 0, correct?
Yes, just now we have seen this.
Now, as a special case, you take
a EIX to be equal to EI.
Now is E equal to 0?
The age equal to 0 no.
A is not equal to 0.
Now if you do 8 transpose then
this would be 000.
The I eighth position will be
one and all others are zero.
And one.
This is the eighth position.
Umm.
Then you have a.
Then you have a 0000 I get
position one and then all the
Into one.
zeros correct.
Umm.
Now, what do you get out of
this?
Meena, A, AE E.
No, if you if you multiply a
with this vector, what do you
get?
E.
No.
I personally think.
Some value X I ^2.
111.
No, please think about it.
Not if you multiply.
Should I give an example?
Yeah.
Thank you, Sir please.
123456 uh 789.
Hmm.
Let me take my E2010.
10, OK.
So what do you get if you
multiply this with this?
So I will get two.
Don't know.
Two second case, third case.
Yes, five eat.
Now what I want to multiply.
010 with 258 what do I get like
so if I take E2 it is 2 cross
Umm.
Umm 5.
two element here correct?
You twist it.
Twist too close to element, yes.
OK.
If I take an E3, what I will
get?
9.
Nine.
911 yeah.
If I get a event I will get a
one correct.
So if I do this, this is nothing
but Sai.
Like 1,000,000.
You agree that I I I element of
a.
Uh, yes, yes, yes, very good,
yeah.
Yes.
Yes, Sir.
Ikami, which in place which
implies that yeah, I I which is
OK.
the I8 element of a.
This is I comma I this is more
than zero for all like so if you
That is true.
have this is one of the
conditions we check for for
positive definite test that is
what we are correct.
OK.
That will entries are strictly
positive.
OK.
Later on, we'll prove that even
the eigenvalues are positive,
and you can have a you can have
a a thing, so if you.
I don't know kritika have you?
Have you seen this properties?
Yes, Sir.
Uh, if you have a matrix a,
let's say A3, by what?
Diagonal interest.
Diagonal entries?
No Sir.
Not actually entries, Sir.
You can also have this is say
A11.
This is a 12.
This is a 13A21A22A23A31A32A33.
Now if you have.
This element will be more than
0.
The determinant of this matrix
is more than zero and the
determinant of this matrix is
more than zero.
All of them are more than zero
then a possibility.
That is true.
Sir, what was the 2nd sentence
then?
A is.
Then the is positive definite.
A11 is more than 0.
The determinant of A11.
The determinant of a one one.
Yeah, I want to A1A22 is more
than 0 determinant and
determinant of A is more than
zero.
If these three are true, then
you have.
Yeah, to be a positive definite
matrix. OK.
OK.
This is a characterization of
positive definite matrices.
You die.
You can values are all positive.
Then it is positive definite.
That is also his condition,
which you can which I will tell
the next class.
OK.
So in that products and norms
are very closely related in that
product of two numbers.
And if you take the dot product
of two then it is norm of X.
So you can do this.
Uh ** and square root and they
defend it to be the norm of X.
It satisfy all the property, not
every norm is induced by an
inner product.
OK, now what are the properties
of norm you should do?
What are the properties of norm?
And Norm is more than 0 correct.
Yes.
Client should not equal to 0.
Whenever X is equal to 0, norm
of X will be equal to 0 and norm
of Lambda X will be equal to
Lambda times normal mod Lambda
times norm of X and then norm of
X + y will be less than equal to
norm of X plus norm of X.
We should satisfy all these
things.
OK, if there is an inner
product, the inner product will
OK.
induce a norm.
For example, this ** is there so
this will induce a norm.
So if you do this operation
inner part of X with X, it'll
induce a norm.
Now this is a very special case,
but not all norms have a
corresponding inner product.
So one example is a Manhattan.
Now you can also have something
called as a Cauchy Schwarz
inequality, where you say that
X&Y the inner quantity is
less than equal to norm of X
times norm of Y.
Now we can have a proof of this,
the.
Yeah, but we need to have a
little bit of algebra for for
that now.
Hey, you are there with me.
I yes VENKITESWARAN there.
OK.
OK, only you are there or
somebody else is also there.
So that only few are with you.
I mean, I think this is we very
frank with you, Sir.
It's going for where few of
things so.
Which one is going?
I I agree, I agree.
I see that the purpose of you
agree with whom?
I'm not sure that I'm.
Maybe maybe this is, you know,
going too fast for me as well,
I'm very frank, like, but it's
going, yeah.
Sir.
I have probably you know I I got
lost somewhere in between and
Ohh.
I'm not sure if I would be able
to catch up this class now
during this session.
Same with me, Sir. I'm.
I if you are observing the
people are dropping also.
I mean, just because I'm not
sure if not getting or what, but
it's really going beyond.
The purpose of.
So, Sir, if we even cover less,
but at least we understand is
more beneficial for all of us, I
I can see like few of us are,
maybe explored and they're
getting a lot of things but not
It.
of all, all of us.
And if you take the percentage
of people, it would be very less
who are understanding
everything.
We can take the vote if we want.
I don't know what to say.
So you your way of explaining is
really good, but not yeah.
Once, once, once, once, once,
once.
Let me let me let me let me
reiterate the purpose of
enabling MIC itself was to raise
your hand when things are not
clear.
When people are very silent, I
tend to assume that you have
understood these things.
Now, where is it that you have
not understood?
So you should raise your hand
immediately and say that this
step requires some other
explanation.
You please explain this now.
I don't blame you, but you
cannot completely say now I lost
somewhere and then that
somewhere is undefined.
But yeah, yeah.
So I think the problem is that
there are so many concepts here
and each of the concept needs
practice.
So I am hitting most of these
terms for the very first time.
I did not do that in my
engineering.
Hmm.
Now when I'm hearing them, and
if we just spend a minute and
move forward to the next slide,
I would not be able to remember
that definition after three
slides.
And then if you are using that
in another definition, so this
is the problem that I am facing.
Maybe.
You.
I'm not sure if others are also
in the same boat or not.
Alright, OK, I understand this.
So I had to turn it down saying
that if you go to your team's
account, my TEAMS post all these
materials well ahead of time.
So for example, if you see in
the in the general category.
And you can you can.
You can you can see the notes
and when you go to Canvas page
in canvas page you can find the
the LECTURES uploaded by
Tuesday, Tuesday, Wednesday of
every week for the upcoming
Saturday class.
Agreed.
Have you found that or should I
show that you know?
Able to found itself.
No, no.
We can find that.
Yeah.
You can find her.
Can't find it we can able to
find it Sir.
What?
So did you go through that?
So if you just go through those
twenty that is slides, you'll
know.
So in the upcoming class on
Saturday, maybe you spend half
an hour, you need inner product,
you need something like this.
You need this so these are the
four concepts.
If you prepare little one page
note also then it will be nice.
Now, while I can't blame but the
machine learning doesn't.
Uh, you know, doesn't spare any
of these topics, so I am unable
to cut down on any of them.
I can go a little slow.
So you indicate to me whenever I
am crossing my my my threshold
and I'll be able to explain it
better.
Now I don't want you to to have
too much memory, but then
wherever you are finding it
difficult, you tell me the so
that I can work out some other
thing.
That's how we worked out the tea
example on the coffee example.
Now those things can be worked
out here also.
So you tell me where is it that
I should start now?
We have 15 minutes of that.
So for every concept you can
give for every concept, you can
give examples like you explained
tea and coffee to most people
can relate and then you know
understand because everything is
new to people, right?
So examples would help that that
was my point.
No, but.
I think bye.
Bye.
I am ready to give examples.
My 1D point is where should I
start from?
So Sir, you explained couple of
times like basis you explained
Umm.
So Sir.
null.
So if you can give me something.
So for example, we can start
that norm, Sir.
The norm, Sir?
From there we can have some
examples.
Yep.
OK, so you don't understand
norms.
Yes, Sir.
I'm asking you, do you don't
understand norms or?
And.
Yes, yes, right, Sir.
Yeah.
No, Sir, no Sir.
So actually when when they when
you have posted at the PPT,
that's the first time seeing of
the norms itself, because I'm
from the non the engineering
type of stuff most I'm able to
get with the matrix and stuff
which is able to understand the
certain things which I have to
spend at least two to three
hours of time or for you to get
for me to at least listen to
your classes.
That's why I'm start preparing,
but the most of the people who
aren't able to get that kind of
investment in time because for
the classes which we have taken
for the certain stuff, I have to
spend, I have spent it at least
two to three hours on nights to
get some something so I can have
put up some questions.
Most peoples weren't able to get
this stuff.
But I I see there was more than
20 years of experience, peoples
are actually they weren't even.
I remember matrix.
That's I I very appreciate you
have actually sending this PPT
ahead so we can prepare.
That's the only think.
So you know you can see that was
141 people's only on the call.
No matter how many examples he
gives right without homework,
people are not going to be able
to catch up, right?
OK, let me let us some waste
time at least.
So that's just accept.
It.
Yes, that's for sure.
At least let.
Let us let us let us let us
spend some time.
Since you told me something.
Tea.
Suppose suppose.
What?
Yeah.
Sorry.
Sorry to interrupt us.
SO11 best thing what we could do
is let's take a take a backward
Umm.
or like a call if you're.
If you're teaching me in the
classes, you are at least you
give two to three work nodes
which we can work on that basis
because that makes you peoples
to at least try for it.
So for each and every norm that
was exercised there.
But if you have a provide some,
make some simple questions or or
exercises, but just which which
is very easy and the solvable
for me.
For them, it makes a positive
feel that they can solve it.
That is the only thing if you
are taking a norm actually
Hmm.
present.
If you give a simple like a two
to two matrix, how to solve this
stuff?
Starting a new concept, if you
give you exercise to them, they
will feel proud that they will
solving it when you're going on
4 into 4-5 into five that kind
of day they can boost some
confident enough for them, they
can solve it.
That's the only thing because
most people dropping the call.
OK.
Bye bye Neil.
What is your name?
Yes, I'm Lakshmi azar.
Lakshman, I have only one
comment on this.
This.
OK.
I have only one comment.
No.
The point is you have enrolled
for a course on data science and
I have been given this Herculean
task that you will be ready with
machine learning concepts and
whatever math is required for
that.
While I can certainly do a two
by two matrix, but my data is of
the order of 1,000,000 cross
hundred.
I have already shown you in
image processing how this data
Yes.
is getting popular.
I don't know whether you are
there for the class or not,
Yes, I'm impressed with the
demos though.
right?
Yeah.
So, but the point is we have to
catch up at some point.
And if you don't have time, I am
just asking you saying that I
will try to take up that time.
So next week I know that I need
little more time to get the
eigenvalues, eigenvectors
etcetera.
I always and requested students
to be a little more and
No.
attentive and give their
feedback then and there.
Now that you've told me that
you're not understood norms, I
will tell you what is the
concept of a norm.
So let's not waste anytime
further now.
Henceforth, I will not wait for
these things.
You cannot keep sitting and then
say, Sir, what is this true 2-3
comma?
Eight, I don't understand
anything.
We have crossed that stage long
back, so whenever it is there
Is in.
even for a single student, you
you please.
That's the reason that I unmute
everybody.
The first thing I do used to
unmute everybody.
You should make use of that
opportunity.
Tika doesn't matter, so I'm
going to tell you something
Fine.
called norms.
I have a wood.
If I have to measure the length
of a wood, what do I do?
You have to know that the
height, the vector of bed
Next one next X1X2, then X 1 -,
X two so.
Very simple.
tonight.
No, you.
This is what I don't know.
You people get things very
complicated and this is what
people do in their doctor's
clinic also or not.
They have a high high scale so
they place is wooden log
somewhere here and then they
read out this body correct?
Is.
Yes, Sir.
Yes, yes.
OK, now imagine can the length.
Yes, Sir.
Yep.
Of any law X be less than 0.
No.
No.
So it is greater than zero.
Now length of a wooden log equal
to 0 implies there is no log
right.
Well, yes, yes.
Yes.
Agree.
Yes, Sir.
Agreed.
OK, now if you have length of X
+ Y, this will always be less
Is her.
Yeah.
than length of X plus length of
right.
Now these are basically the
three properties which I'm going
to tell you.
The third is called a triangle
inequality.
And this length function should
satisfy everything.
This length is actually only
called as a norm in higher
dimension set, so in higher
dimensions I called something as
a norm and then say norm of X is
some quantity which is always
more than zero.
So again, norm of X equal to 0
implies X equal to zero 30s Tom
of X + y is less than or equal
to norm of X plus norm of Y.
Now for all X comma, Y.
Now these are the three
properties of the norms.
Now I will give you some
examples of knobs.
So one is I have a non X.
But what?
So what is why you here?
Why is another blog?
So is there any difference
between norms and modulus?
Because the we we know the same
property with the modulus as
well.
Yeah.
So I'm gonna give you that only
as now norm of X in the
Manhattan norm.
Now this is what is norm of 1.
This is nothing but you take
some of all the X's, the
components I equal to 1 to him
where your ex is nothing but
X1X2 to X.
X2 to X so for example.
If X is nothing but one minus
1207, then norm of X in the one
norm is nothing but Sigma I
equal to 1 to N norm of X, which
is equal to 1 + 1 of minus one
plus mod of two plus mod of 0
plus mod of seven.
This is 1 + 1 + 2 + 0 + 7 which
is equal to 11. Agree.
So can you repeat again?
Uh, just normal fix again.
Yeah, you take the sum of
absolute values of all the
components of X in higher
dimensions.
Right.
Well, you were an example.
If the X is 1 -, 1, two, 07, the
norm of X1 for this X is nothing
but mod of 1 plus mod of minus
one plus mod of 0 plus mod of
two plus mod of 0 plus mod of
seven, which is 1 + 1 + 2 + 0 +
7 which is equal to 11. Agree.
Well, the minus one become plus
one here and one.
Right.
Yes, I am.
Because it's an absolute value.
No.
Agreed, Sir.
OK, OK, Now I have to prove that
this satisfies all the
properties listed above,
correct?
Solutely.
OK, so I will talk about the
first property first property
now norm of X1 is nothing but
Sigma I equal to 1 to North mod
of exit.
You know mod is always a
positive function, so some of
Wanna fix it?
all positive numbers will not be
more than 0.
Yes.
Yeah.
Right.
So what's first property
satisfied second property?
Yes, yes.
Let's say norm of X1 is equal to
0, which implies.
Marta Vixen Plus mode of X2 plus
all the day of two mod of Exxon
will be equal to 0, correct?
Yes.
And.
Now this will imply how can the
sum of N positive numbers B
equal to 0.
And all the values will would be
0.
So.
Well, I said I either.
X1 is equal to 0 or X2 is equal
to 0 up to X and equal to 0
correct which implies exceeds
will be equal to 0.
Looks into school correct Sir.
Yeah.
Yes.
Yes.
Second property satisfied.
Yes.
So now I will take norm of.
Yes.
Uh X + y.
One, no, this is nothing but
Sigma I equal to 1 trillion mod
of XI plus Y8, correct.
Got it.
Now you know this property for
mod.
This is nothing but Sigma I
equal to 1 to N this norm of X +
y mod of X + y will be less than
or equal to mod of XI plus mod
of I agree.
Like so.
Yeah.
Is this equal to Sigma I equal
to 1 to N now mod of XI plus
Sigma I equal to 1 to N mod of
Y?
This is equal to norm of X1 plus
norm of X.
Agreed.
Yes.
I just.
Yes, Sir.
Well, I have proved all the
three properties for this
definition of what?
So this becomes a knob.
Got it, Sir.
But yes, yes, yes Sir.
Got it.
OK.
Yes, Sir.
Now let me ask one question to
the TS.
Kritika and APARNA.
Are you there?
It said Kathy Ankit.
Good.
They got you are also here now.
Yes, Sir.
I'm also here.
You want to prove this is now
makes 2.
Sigma mod X i.e.
Square I equal to 1 together
HARIKA you are from pure
mathematics or applied
mathematics background.
Applied mathematics.
OK, then I can make it slightly
tough for you.
Ohh.
Sigma equal to 1 to N mod XI to
the P pole power one by P.
Now tell me if you have to prove
this to be these to be norms.
And what is the kind of
inequality you use?
And because he's questioning
quality.
Which one?
KASHTE questioning quality, Sir.
No, but even fundamental there
is something called holders
inequality.
Or Minkowski is in quality.
Anyway.
And yes, Sir.
Yes.
How are you doing?
For others, no need to get
signed by these things.
Basically the point is, there
are other inequalities in
mathematics which can help you
prove all these things.
I'm just quoting them.
You don't have to go through
that, but these are proven facts
you have to take each one in its
own spirit, and then you have to
do it.
Now the the first.
The first one is actually the
special case of the second one,
where P is equal to two agree.
But I can define it for any
general P.
How fast?
Yes, Sir.
First one is distance between
two points.
Everything is distance now the
the the point is this.
Yeah, yeah.
These are all distances, but the
only point is what I've written
for P equal to two here can be
generalized for P equal P here,
and if you are ever trying to
prove that this is an
Hi.
inequality, you have minkowski's
inequality.
Whole days inequality actually
mikos is inequality is proved
from whole days inequality.
So you can use these two
inequalities to do that, but I
don't want any of the data since
students to get into this, but
there are proofs available in
the market, just have that
concept.
Anyway, time is up for the
present class, so in next class
I will, uh have to do.
Uh. Considerably?
I have to do some 222023 slides
so I might take about an hour or
so and then start with the
Lecture.
So I hope I will clarify things
slowly, but give me some time
and then you also ask these
questions, OK.
That is it possible to give some
some exercise and norms?
Shows up.
Covered.
Yes, Sir.
Your voice is too low.
Is it possible to?
Get some exercise on norms.
Access.
Exercise.
Yeah, he's saying he's saying
can you get some exercises when
I didn't questions simple
questions.
they can?
We can practice.
I have the.
I don't know whether you people
are reading the the actual
announcements in one of the
announcements I have put, there
is a book called linear algebra
by Gilbert Strang.
Did you have a look at it?
Yes, Sir.
Yeah.
That time I'll look.
Yeah.
He does 300 problems there.
Yes, that was a announcement,
Sir.
And I have to solve umm.
Yeah, it is an announcement.
So it has 300 problems there.
I have not been able to do even
five of them.
I I can cut and paste from there
and give it in the canvas
portal.
Will it help?
Another we can referendum and if
you Google will get a lot of
Then I'll say I'll look in the
books I know.
places.
Yeah, you, you, you Google that
book, you will get it and then
you can do start doing this and
you can bring some questions
here in the class and then we
can do that if you come
prepared, we can discuss more
items and then I can tell you
some tips and tricks which are
being used in maths and we can
do that.
But that's somehow not gaining
momentum.
Let me also find out a way by
which they can be done OK.
Thank you, Sir.
Is it possible for to share
questions content, paste the one
What quest?
What is?
cause no, no, just now you told
right cut and paste questions
What is the question you are
looking for?
and share in the canvas.
I'm going.
I'm telling you, if I have to
cut and paste and to cut and
paste from Gilbert Strang only.
Yes.
Please, that's what I am.
I'm I'm referring to.
How are you?
Yeah, I have a.
What now?
You know, I am your TA.
You expect me to if you type
Gilbert Strang linear algebra,
you'll be able to get this.
I also wrote saying that he has
given several YouTube videos.
Now in his book, which is really
downloadable, he has given some
500 problems or so you want.
OK.
When you said I will search it
up.
I can take a screenshot of it
and post it to you.
Send a WhatsApp to you, but that
is not going to solve any
problem in my opinion.
If you want looking for problems
on positive definiteness or
norms, etcetera, you download
the book and then you have 300
problems straight away.
There are some 1012 problems
here.
God.
Solved and there are some 1520
problems in each exercise, which
is left as you know, access
problems if you are not able to
solve any excess problem you
write to me or to my TS they
will be helping you to solve
these problems.
Agree but me trying to they are
not my problems.
Got it, got it.
Well, kisses.
In a sense, you know, I should
be very honest in saying those
problems are very neatly
articulated better than me.
So I think it is better that you
start doing it from a book and
you can also look at the section
number and you can also go
through go back and forth
etcetera and then do those
problems.
Any doubts you please ask me.
OK.
Because I'll tell the LECTURES
slides so.
Got it.
I said just one question.
OK, Sir.
So can we move to your octave
notebook?
Yeah.
I just want to know the trick
you used to find those bases
vector R2 and R3.
Where you were making those
notes?
The one basis vector was 10 and
01.
The others you told were one,
three, and four.
Seven.
I believe so.
Yeah.
What was the trick you used?
Without calculations you were
able to identify those 3
vectors.
Ah, the the point is this.
Now if you have two vectors, you
especially if you form them as
column vectors and you see the
determinant is nonzero, they
will always be a a basis.
Like the trick is, uh, the
determinant should be non 0.
Yeah, exactly.
OK.
Yeah, somebody was telling me
something.
Other than the lecture slides,
is it available?
Uh meeting bug or?
Your voice is still not very
clearly audible.
Can somebody translate it?
Except for the lecture slides,
what you used you said table in
See.
teams.
Yes, Sir.
Really, you just see this?
Lecture say it's supposed to.
It alright.
No Lecture slides are posted on
canvas portal.
Should I show that to you?
And what?
OK, I'll find out.
Checking I will searching
things.
Yeah. Thanks.
They're under module sections.
They are posted, Sir.
No, he's asking in teams.
In teams it is not.
In teams, we just post whatever
notes I'm I'm doing now.
That if if necessary, I can post
that also there are no problem I
Missing animal.
can do that Sir.
Thank you.
OK.
Uh, so there, so the
announcement there is a mention
about webinar schedule where it
is 12th December, the 7:30 to
Yeah.
9:00 PM.
How so?
The OK can you just give a
brief?
Like, how's it different from
the normal Lecture?
Yeah, sure.